good morning John you probably don't
know this but I was actually one of the
first people in America to know that the
vote was going to be a thing I got to
interview the designers and the people
working on the drivetrain and the people
who designed the concept car and it was
super cool and somewhere around you
actually have an unopened box concept
Chevrolet Volts so yeah I'm jealous done
in the past few years I haven't visited
you enough in Indianapolis and frankly
that's just because you didn't have a
volt so I'll see you soon on my video
about Porto Rico a couple of days ago I
got a lot of questions about the House
of Representatives and what it is and
how representatives are assigned and why
it exists so today I explained the House
of Representatives and I hope that's an
OK way to end Brotherhood 2.0 week oh my
god it's already over it went so fast it
was so difficult so the house
representatives here's what happened
back of the day a bunch of white guys
got into a fight so we're like oh every
state should get the same representation
and government some of them were like no
even oMG should only be based in
population dudes are those - very funny
sounding people reached across the aisle
as it were and they made a compromise
they created two branches of Congress
the Senate which would have the same
number of Representatives for every
state - in the House of Representatives
which would have a different number of
Representatives for each state based on
how many people actually live in that
state the house started off with 65
seats basically one for every 60,000 of
the four million ish people in America
in 1790 at first these geniuses were
like oh let's just keep adding a chair
for every 60,000 new people America gets
I'm sure that'll never be a problem
except that of course if we had kept
doing that there would now be over 5,000
people in the House of Representatives
around 1910 it became very clear that
this was a terrible idea because they
were gonna have to rename it the stadium
instead of the house so the gap the
number right where they were which was
435 which is where we still are today
and I remembered that number by saying
the phrase Need for Speed four letters
three letters five letters and of course
this was the video game that I was
playing in 1996 when I took civics 435
isn't in the Constitution or anything
but it has been in place for a really
long time over a hundred years so it's
really unlikely that that number will
ever go up again today as the population
has increased in the number of seats in
the House hasn't we now have one
representative for roughly every 700,000
people but this raises the question what
happens if 700,000 people decide that
Oregon smells bad it doesn't it's lovely
but just for the sake of our
and they all move to Washington which is
pine fresh well now Oregon suddenly has
more representatives than it deserves in
Washington has fewer this is one of the
reasons if you're wondering why we do
with census because when we do the
census we then redistribute the
Representatives based on any population
changes that have occurred in this case
one of the representatives from Oregon
would just lose his or her job and there
would be a new seat open in Washington
for Washingtonian politicians to fight
over now onto the case of hypothetically
a whole other state joining our union
because Puerto Rico has about four
million people we have to do a whole
bunch of crazy math to figure out how to
represent them properly in the House of
Representatives it automatically get two
senators just for being a state and one
representative every state gets at least
one but in addition it would also
deserve four or possibly five
representatives all its own now because
we can't add to the 435 we have to take
those representatives from other places
based on the populations of those places
according to a nice detailed report that
I found on the internet Florida
Washington Texas California and
Minnesota would lose one representative
each those representatives will be
unable to run for re-election and those
seats would then be fought for by Puerto
Rican politicians so yes Puerto Rico
because of its fairly large population
would have quite a bit of sway in the
House of Representatives certainly more
than Montana does we only get the one
John this concludes our week of
Brotherhood 2.0 style videos and it was
really fun and I wish we could keep
doing it it's just that we have all this
other stuff to do with crash course and
scishow and stuff hopefully
nerdfighteria thinks that it's worth it
John I'll see you on Tuesday
nerdfighteria calm go